la mayoría busca llegar a eeuu pero no
siempre es posible durante décadas la
violencia obligó a buscar una nueva vida
a migrantes centroamericanos y
colombianos pero en la actualidad la
pobreza la exclusión y el cambio
climático son las otras causas que
suelen empujar a los latinoamericanos en
su éxodo
2021 ha visto cómo se generaban tres
puntos calientes en la región iquique en
chile en necoclí en colombia y tapachula
en mexico estas ciudades han aparecido
de forma recurrente en la actualidad
internacional en iquique los migrantes
quedan atrapados llegaron buscando una
mejor vida y se encontraron con
dificultades para obtener un empleo y
documentos necoclí es la última parada
antes de cruzar el peligroso tapón del
darién a panamá en 2021 90.000 personas
intentaron cruzar esta selva medio
centenar murió y tapachula a ciudad
fronteriza con guatemala donde muchos
migrantes se ven cercados y sin
escapatoria por las autoridades
mexicanas
de hecho méxico es la última parada
antes de llegar a eeuu la administración
bailén ha detenido más de 1,7 millones
de personas en su frontera en 2021
mientras que la de andrés manuel lópez
obrador ha detenido a más de 228 mil
en los últimos años han migrado un total
de 6 millones de venezolanos pero
también ha crecido la migración haitiana
que huye de la crisis interna pero
también hay aquellos que se
establecieron en países como chile y la
pandemia del cob y 19 acabó con su
estabilidad por delante un camino
incierto de violencia trata de personas
y explotación sexual y múltiples
peligros que para muchos es incluso más
seguro que sus propios lugares de origen